[Music]
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with a columnist
Carol Malone and the editor of The
Courier in Dundee David Clegg they'll be
with us from now right up until just
before midnight so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
the Metro's front page focuses on
missing mother Nicola Bully's family
hitting out about speculation over her
personal life their headline just focus
on
finding Nikki
it's the same story for the sun don't be
afraid Nikki come home
The Daily Mail focuses on the Home
Secretary Sarah bravaman's intervention
in the case
David's paper The Courier has an
exclusive as the SNP Deputy leader John
Swinney tells them he won't stand in the
contest to replace Nicholas sturgeon as
Scotland's first minister
the financial times reports on
speculation that an unscheduled trip to
Belfast by Rishi Sue neck could mean a
post-brexit Northern Ireland protocol
agreement is signed soon
that's also the main story for the
telegraph
and the star offers an analysis of
Britain's sleeping habits on
flatteringly they compare us all to
zombies
and remind you that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by Carl Malone
and David Clegg welcome to both of you
let us start with the metro and their
headline just focus on finding Nikki and
this coming at a point where police have
been heavily criticized after finding no
sign of her after three weeks of their
investigation also the investigation
being criticized as well Carol
I mean you know if we we were talking
about this about 10 days ago the police
were operating in a very bizarre where
usually when someone goes missing in
this way they're a very clicked back
into your followers and lags police
don't have followed any of them you know
their their press conferences at the
point they didn't have a press
conference for certain days which I find
astonishing because David will go to
visit what's got me singing it's a big
high profile case but press need to be
given details every day of Interest so
people keep looking that didn't happen
you know we've had the police really
today
she had drug alcohol problems and had
problems with the menopause
into my first information there should
never have been released perhaps that
she had if she had mental health issues
say that don't talk about HRT 100
nipples it's it's obsessive
that's not what they are
themselves at the moment
that release some details but not what
they have you know and the books seem to
be playing the blame game not released
in these details this was to divert
attention
on this case you know they have that
they've released these data in the
beginning not about menopause but about
to have been vulnerable
this might have made a difference to the
way the spiritual was carried out but
they they kind of do it the people it
just seems to me it's like they've never
done it before you
Rebecca
huge superintendent now
Rebecca Smith beat it at the press
conference the other day and the drugs
that looked like she was going to a
cocktail party it just was it was
outrageous I was thinking do you guys
know how to conduct an investigation she
was trying to blame Tick Tock saying
there were putting her team up from
doing their job well Tick Tock that
shouldn't be putting that team off from
doing that they should know how to be
doing their job now we know that they're
being questioned that we were saying
today the referred them to the eye of
the PC not entirely true because the
iopc what we're looking at to see if an
investigation was warranted so they've
referred themselves before they were
hauled into it it's just been a disaster
from start to finish yes and it said the
repercussions of the uh police action
that the family is saying that they're
aware that Lancashire police released a
statement with some personal details and
saying that Nicola would not have wanted
this
and there are people out there
threatening to sell stories about her
yes I think it must be extremely
upsetting for the family and it does
seem like this has been a failure of
execution with the police I think every
journalist who runs a newspaper who
deals with their local police on on
stories like that realizes that there
are operational reasons for things that
they can tell you and that they can't
tell you uh and that they always very
much should have the interests of the
families that are affected by whatever
the situation is and and how they go
about that now that is more complicated
when you do have social media where you
do have a lot of conspiracy theories
that were being that were floating
around on social media and the impact
that was was having the police have an
obligation to control that to deal with
that and and work through that in the
best way possible and I think what's
clear here is that they got it wrong
early on they didn't have uh it didn't
have that private conversation
journalist that goes on a lot where they
said uh or they can say here's what's
going on in the background please let
that steer your coverage but don't
publish these details because they would
be unhelpful or upsetting and then that
has then forced them into a situation
where they've had to reveal more than
what the family would want uh what would
normally be the case and I think we've
seen by the reaction widespread
reactions that aren't through a lot of
um a lot of political on both sides uh
uh labor and the conservatives concerned
about what's going on there and it is
very unusual for politicians to talk so
starkly about the operational uh
execution of a of a police investigation
so I think that shows that something has
gone wrong here and it's probably
something that will need to be looked at
more thoroughly uh afterwards yeah well
we're going to come on to um Sorella
bradman's uh comments but the sun
covering the family's direct appeal to
Nicola to come home we all need you home
they say
cow yeah and I hope to God she's still
able to come home I hope she's watching
this coverage and able to come home but
you know I I you know having seen the
details of the stuff that's been
released today that could happen that if
she is still with us you know I I don't
know what the police thought they were
gonna how it would move the
investigation on by releasing details
about her stopping taking her HRT and
her menopause if she is out there and
she is in a state that's going to put
her off coming home they've done a lot
more damage than good here you know her
partner has been talking very early on
and asking police to search the field
suits and surrounding areas search
people's houses but but the police in
Lancaster seem to have decided what
happened to Nicola they seem to have
decided right from day one that she
slipped into the water that that's what
happened to her and although they've
said from the start they're open-minded
about everything else they haven't been
open-minded at all
to the male David and as we we made
mention of um briefly before swella
bravaman not happy at all with the the
police handling of the case has concerns
about that decision by Lancashire
constabulary to release that that highly
personal information and it's quite
unusual for for the Home Secretary to to
get involved in a police investigation
at this stage isn't it
almost unprecedented I think that they
would they would talk in that terms with
a live investigation you often hear
subsequently or or after events have
included that they may reflect on what
happened and make comments of this
nature but I think for as well a
Braverman to talk this explicitly about
her concern about the way the way it's
happening this is not the detail of you
know what steps they're taking uh to to
look for Nicola it's about the way what
they're releasing to the media what
they're releasing publicly the way that
that is being done and I think that
reflects the the Deep concern about not
only the impact that could have on the
people involved in this situation but
also other people in similar
circumstances who dread the idea of this
type of private information ever been
made available about them so I think
there there is probably a conversation
to be had about whether the Home
Secretary should be publicly
accommodating that publicly on a live
police investigation even those who
agree with her comments may have some
concern about that because there does
need to be operational Independence of
the police in these types of situations
and even the Home Secretary won't be
aware of every granular detail of the
investigation as the way those who are
leading it will be so we'll see how that
pans out I think in the 10 months ahead
but certainly I think this has raised a
lot of wider questions about how the
police operate in the New Media climate
that we're in now uh I think it's almost
certainly the case that their decisions
have been driven by the types of fevered
speculation that unchecked speculation
that nigh can go uh viral on social
media how they calculate what their
priorities are in this situation as far
as stamping out rumors making it clear
what's going on while retaining people's
privacy and calculating what it's useful
for the public to know as far as they're
getting the investigation is concerned
and what is not I don't think there's no
doubt that these are difficult judgments
uh the police deal with them every day
across the country
journalists wrestle with similar issues
every day across the country but it
certainly feels like when we get to the
stage of the news that we're seeing
today that something something's gone
badly wrong interesting point that you
raise uh David uh Carol do you think
that the Home Secretary should be
passing comment on a live police
investigation yes yes I do because I
think she's had to intervene because the
police are not doing this very well and
I and I hear what David just said there
about them you know judging what they do
and how they kind of duck their
investigation between about what's
happening on social media that should
not be the case that's a diversion they
should have a a plan of how they're
going to try and find her and and this
and looking at what people saying on
social media that's just a petty
diversion forget what they're doing do
your job and try and find her don't be
judging and thinking how I'm going to
conduct it this way because of what's
happening on Tick Tock and this woman
Rebecca Smith actually mentioned Tick
Tock and said that they were disturbing
that's nonsense nothing should deter the
investigate
that obviously has been the sustained
backlash over them revealing um
this bully struggles with with alcohol
and that the menopause women's
campaigners uh saying that officers were
in fact trying to hide their own
incompetence by revealing these extra
details I mean would you agree with that
David
sorry could you say that again I didn't
quite catch that I was having a bit of
sign trouble then okay yeah sorry I was
just saying that the the police
revealing the details about her
struggles with alcohol and the the
menopause it's called women campaigners
women's campaigners to say that it's
really because officers are trying to
hide their own incompetence and that's
why they're revealing these further
details now
I think it's certainly the case that
when they're doing at this stage you
have to wonder well what what else has
changed uh to think that it's not
operationally useful for them to do that
it's very strange for it to happen after
that length of time I think it almost
certainly reflects the fact that uh the
way the information flow had went
earlier in the investigation had been
problematic but that it feels like
something that's maybe been done in
panic I've heard some people question
about who exactly had sign off from this
my understanding is the first mention of
it came in a press release uh who
exactly had side of it who made the
decision I think I think there is a lot
of questions to be to be answered there
and certainly when you get to this type
of situation where
uh
it seems pretty clear that mistakes have
been made they they are they almost cert
certainly have been engineered by uh
previous mistakes earlier on in the
chain now well it was an attempt to
cover them up I would I would I'm I'm
not certain I would like to draw that
conclusion at this point but I think
that regardless of the fact and it will
be uh cool Comfort uh to the family
involved but that there has been there
has been errors here and it's and it's
caused a great deal of difficulty yeah
and just very quickly uh Carol just uh a
former missing person specifically asked
if Nicola was suffered from depression
or any other underlying conditions and
they chose at that point not to tell
anyone why did they do that you know
they should that would have changed the
way they are searching for her if they
had released that information but they
were asked specifically and they they
said no which is just which means the
hiding thing
yes and the the paper just quoting a
former missing person's expert at
Scotland Yard saying the failure by
police to State earlier why they thought
Miss bully had drowned had created an
unnecessary uh circus we have run out of
time in this section so I'm going to
thank you both for the moment and we are
going to take a break stay right to
where you are
coming up a d and intensive care nurses
are to strike for the first time or
discuss that and more coming up
[Music]
you are watching The Press preview still
with me Cara Malone and David Clegg
there they both are let us have a look
at the Courier who should we go to on
this story David why don't you have a go
I think you've heard of this newspaper
this is the story about the Persia MSP
saying that it's time for a fresh
perspective not throwing his hat into
the ring this is John Swinney
yeah this is John Swinney the deputy
first minister of Scotland uh a close
confident of negro sturgeons for many
years someone who has been a fixture on
the Scottish political scene for decades
he was in fact leader of the SMP between
2000 and 2004 prior to Alex salmon
taking that position uh so there had I
think a lot of people who were looking
for stability in the SMP after Nicholas
sturgeon's shock resignation yesterday
looking perhaps to John Swinney as
someone who could be a voice of
consistency of stability who could uh
keep the show on the roads so I think um
my newspaper interviewed him this
morning and I think even he was
surprised not only about how many people
had contacted him asking him to do that
but also the fact that he had been quite
tempted because I think it's fair to say
that his first experience of leader of
the SMP uh was not something that he
particularly enjoyed perhaps so I think
what that what this which is a it's a
big story it's a it's a it's a great
exclusive for us to have on our front
page tomorrow and I think one of the
things it shows us at this SMP
leadership contest following Nicholas
thurston's departure it is going to have
a lot of new ideas a lot of new faces uh
Nicola sturgeon obviously came in in
2014 as first Minister after Alex
Salmons were vital contest it's been
quite a while since the party has had a
public conversation about Direction
about why they should pursue the case
for Independence so one of the things
that they were worried about perhaps is
about how divisive it will be whether
there be public bloodletting because we
know there's a range of issues in which
there is disagreement and how they and
if they can present a united front again
to the Scottish like running up to the
general election and their desire to
pursue a second Independence referendum
the fact that John Sweeney's not going
to be there I think shows that it's
going to be new faces uh and there's
very interesting weeks and months ahead
uh as
quoted uh in your paper saying to create
the space for that fresh perspective to
emerge I've decided not to be a
candidate for leadership in the SMP and
Carol my question to you is that fresh
perspective might that mean no
referendum on Independence
yeah I think for now the independent
stream is dead I mean I think it's you
know the the most recent polls and one
of the reasons that Nicola had jumped
before she was pushed recent pearls said
44 of people still wanted Independence
but 56 didn't so I think it would be
fool party of any new leader to jump in
now and start campaigning for
Independence right away I think it's
going to be put on hold for a while and
and rightly so you know the Scottish
people Sturgill never took the debate
anymore Scotland is exactly the same
place now in terms of polls as it was
before the 2000 well after the 2014
referendum 56 said no to Independence so
she has achieved nothing in terms of
that so so the country is divided now as
it was then so it definitely needs a
fresh perspective she was a very
divisive character I think and I think
not she wasn't just divisive between
Scotland and England I mean I I resented
her for driving a wedge between England
in Scotland but I think she drove a
wedge between the Scottish people
because she wasn't listening to what
people who weren't nationalists wanted
and you know I mean I just I I have so
much contact with the unions in Scotland
and they tell me all the time that she
just what she wanted for Scotland it's
not what they wanted so I think whoever
servers and games is gonna have a tough
job I think whoever the toughest job
they're going to have is try to try and
repair a Scotland that she has literally
wrecked over the past eight years you
know that the budget deficit is 12 of
GDP twice what the UK's is as a home it
was meant you mentioned in one of your
things before that the drug related
death is is three times higher than any
other country in Europe one of the worst
in the world's developed countries she
you know she's produced life expectancy
there she said her mission was to close
the gap between the rich and the poor
it's wider than ever she was going to
create a new Energy company she hasn't
done not you know she has failed on
every level and I don't know how she's
got away with being leader as long as
she has I don't know whether this is the
further of nationalism I don't know yeah
well she survived eight years and we are
going to have to leave it there we've
run over time we haven't didn't manage
to get to the um the Metro but that just
on the escalation of the dispute with
the nurses and the emergency intensive
care units being brought into that
dispute and a 48-hour walkout
Carol and David for the moment thank you